so I said on yesterday's bonus show that
today I was going to go through this new
Middle East peace plan that has been
released by Donald Trump and by Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu so
let's do that but in order to do it we
have to establish a few things first
number one Donald Trump knows nothing
about the israeli-palestinian conflict
he's self congratulating by calling this
the deal of the century he thought Jared
Kushner was going to achieve Middle
Eastern peace
it's a total joke at the get-go and
Trump is completely in over his head
number two this entire thing is absurd
at its face because you have impeached
president Donald Trump and indicted
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu saying
hey we figured out a great plan with no
Palestinian involvement in actually
figuring out this plan so that's
ridiculous and then number three this is
very clearly timed to suppress coverage
of both Donald Trump's impeachment and
Benjamin Netanyahu's indictment
respectively it's laughable at its face
but let's take a little bit of a look at
the parameters to see if we by chance
come across something in this quote deal
that makes sense Palestinian leaders
have rejected the deal on principle
because it includes some annexations of
West Bank land now I've said before I'm
100% against settlements by Israel which
violate international law the
settlements need to stop they need to
stop now and in any realistic long term
peace deal and I'll lay out what that
looks like a little bit later there is
going to be some West Bank land on which
there are settlements likely swapped for
land of equivalent value from Israel for
a Palestinian state Arafat in the 90s
said that it's potentially okay if the
land is equivalent
whatever that means that's gonna have to
be debated but this nothing is going to
happen if there cannot be some land
swaps the deal that Donald Trump and
Benjamin Netanyahu have put forth would
include a four year freeze on new
settlement construction that's a start
the problem with it is that does that
mean that an existing settlement cannot
expand or that simply there can be no
new settlements and that difference is
actually a really significant one it
will also provide a path to power
Estonians for a contiguous territory for
a future Palestinian state when certain
conditions of statehood are met now of
course Palestinians are not going to
agree to the conditions that are
outlined the contiguity of the state is
an important thing and from the maps
that have been put out it looks like
Gaza and the West Bank and a capital in
East Jerusalem would be contiguous based
on on roads that would be made part of
the state
so in principle impeached Trump and
indicted Netanyahu establishing this
without Palestinian involvement is a
joke
Palestinian a Palestinian capital in
East Jerusalem is included in this which
is good but it's mentioned only as part
of East Jerusalem that's going to be a
tough negotiating point as well if there
is ever a negotiation to happen um and
in total this is effectively a political
stunt that's all that this is and
because this has come up and it's an
opportunity to do it let me review my
peace plan and as I said last time I did
this years ago almost everyone is going
to find something they don't like about
what I believe an eventual plan would
look like every good compromise leaves
everyone at least a little bit upset
that's why it's called compromise but
this is the way I would see the most
likely path forward first of all we have
to talk about who's in charge of
negotiations Benjamin Netanyahu is not
going to preside over serious
israeli-palestinian peace it's just not
going to happen he's shown that it is
not in his image it is not in his
interests he benefits from more
attention and and not having any kind of
serious prospect for peace so Benjamin
Netanyahu cannot be the Israeli Prime
Minister if we are going to see serious
opportunities for peace Hamas must be
replaced by a more secular Palestinian
Authority in Gaza right away Hamas is
not going to be a serious negotiator of
peace
what would mahmoud abbas his role be
they're currently in charge of the West
Bank I'm open to expanding the role of
Mahmoud Abbas Hamas does not want that
Hamas is actually assassinated Fatah men
in recent years Abbas has has often
given you no lie riddled speeches at the
United Nations but to the extent that
Abbas might be a productive partner
that's what I care about I'm open to
Abbas being involved in the eventual
secular ideally Palestinian Authority
that would be in charge law of return
for Jews to Israel is going to have to
be maintained I don't see how you put a
deal together without it the the whole
point of Israel is Jews have been and
continue to be discriminated against and
kicked out of so many parts of the world
Israel is a place Jews know they can go
period and as long as that is maintained
I don't know that I care too much about
whether Israel is called a Jewish state
this is a point of contention that I am
sort of flexible on as long as the law
of return remains that that is what I
think is important the Palestinian law
of return for Palestinians to return to
Israel is going to have to be conceded
to some degree and this is something
that certainly governments like the
Netanyahu government have not wanted it
can't be for five million Palestinians
it's just not going to happen so again I
know that a lot of the reaction to this
will be David you're acting like this
wouldn't be fair that wouldn't be fair
I'm trying to get to what is each side
likely going to have to concede to have
a serious opportunity and the Israel is
not going to concede return for five
million Palestinians but some reasonable
number that makes sense should be
included once the blockade on Gaza is
released which it should be anyone who
wants to move back to Gaza or the West
Bank should be free to do so and at that
point it will be up to the Palestinian
Authority to decide how many people will
they allow to move into Gaza and the
West Bank and East Jerusalem in the past
a hoot Barak for example suggested a
symbolic number of Palestinian returners
and otherwise significant financial
reparations and I think that something
like that would would likely be what has
to happen importantly what are the
borders right this is a big point of
contention I believe that the boy
are going to have to be more or less the
proposed Clinton borders from the 1990s
and that's very similar to a lot of the
recent ideas that have been put forward
the Palestinian territory will include
the West Bank and Gaza and East
Jerusalem the problem is that the limits
of East Jerusalem are disputed
that's when Donald Trump says part of
East Jerusalem this conflict is what
he's getting at let's imagine that there
could be an agreement as to what the
lines of East Jerusalem would be
Jerusalem would astir ooh solemn at
whatever agreed-upon borders would be
decided there plus Gaza the West Bank
and against something linking them to
make it a contiguous state Jerusalem
becoming the capital of Israel for
international purposes this is
controversial is many Israelis want this
certainly the Netanyahu government wants
it right now internationally the capital
is Tel Aviv internally Jerusalem is sort
of the capital I'm fine with Jerusalem
becoming the capital of Israel for
international purpose purposes and East
Jerusalem becoming the Palestinian
capital I think that there is going to
have to be some something figured out
with regard to the Jewish quarter of the
old city in East Jerusalem that's
probably going to have to remain under
Israeli sovereignty we could do an
entire show just about that but among a
list of complex options you probably are
going to have to negotiate the Jewish
quarter remaining part of Israel there
was desecration of the Jewish quarter
from 49 to 67 you can read more about
that if you care to but that would
probably be of something that has to
remain under Israeli control of course
Israel has to immediately stop all
settlement building period Israel needs
to agree in principle to remove some
settlements they're gonna have to agree
to remove some settlements to get a deal
done and then again the larger
settlements that are not realistically
speaking going to be dismantled there
will have to be land swaps and the land
swaps have to be of equivalent
meaningful land not all the settlements
at this point are going to realistically
be removed
I wish it were different but this is the
reality as Arafat said in the 90s if
they are meaningful land swaps
it's conceivably something that
Palestinians could be open to the
security situation what happens with
travel and checkpoints and the Gaza
blockade the Palestinians will
immediately and this this is why Hamas
is unlikely to be a good negotiating
partner Palestinians will have to stop
all rocket attacks immediately all
tunnel building would have to stop
immediately and existing tunnels meant
to circumvent the security status quo
would have to be destroyed right away
there would have to be an agreement to
demilitarize Gaza as part of a peace
agreement and in the two-year period
after the withdraw of Israel from Gaza
remember but before the blockade was put
in there were just thousands of rockets
so there must be a demilitarization and
ideally Hamas would simply not be part
of these negotiations as I as much as I
think Benjamin Netanyahu will not be
part of any credible negotiation
I don't think Hamas will be either
Israel has to remove the blockade and
the way that it would have to be done is
conditional Israel will remove the
blockade immediately and as long as
there is a demilitarization in Gaza and
no rocket launches is held to the
blockade removal would have to be held
to as well as part of the agreement and
then a sort of broader key point all
claims must be renounced in other words
both sides have to say as part of this
agreement we renounce claims and this is
the end of the conflict if in the future
things are done that violate that
agreement then they are violating an
international agreement rather than one
of these non-binding things that
negotiators may put together there has
to be a this is the end of the conflict
we renounce all claims this is the
agreement going forward is this likely
to happen anytime soon no it is not and
is it likely to happen under Donald
Trump definitely not